I believe it is the
artist's responsibility
to lead people into hell.
But I also believe it's
important to lead the way out.
We are in a renaissance
of documentary.
People are realizing that there
is as much drama in what is
and what was as anything that
the human imagination dreams up.
And you have the added
advantage of it being true.
In order to be a
good director, you
have to be able to
tolerate contradiction.
There's no objective truth.
This is human experience.
We see things from
different perspectives.
And that's OK.
It's really important
that history not be
distilled to sort of
the Great Men theory.
All of those people
that are famous
don't do the fighting
and the dying.
The best history is the place
where so-called ordinary people
exist.
You want to use everything
at your disposal
to activate your
audience's imagination.
[PUNCHES LANDING]
The cannon firing.
[CANNON FIRING]
Troops tramping.
Bat cracking
There are millions
things that you
can do-- that you have to
do-- until you go, whoa.
That's working.
We find ourselves in one of
the most challenging moments
in the history of
the United States.
The role of the filmmaker then
becomes even more important
and more urgent.
If you've got that thing that
is burning inside you saying,
I have to do this.
Now we can begin to talk
about how you start.
I'm Ken Burns, and this
is my MasterClass.